alors que l'europe et les états unis
sont en pleine deuxième vague de
qu'ovide la chine et ses voisins
asiatiques repartent de l'avant creusant
un peu plus encore l'écart avec les
économies occidentales
avec cette crise l'europe est elle
condamnée à décrocher de la croissance
mondiale pourquoi est il plus difficile
pour nous européens de nous en sortir
on voit ce cas tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir un
jacques bonsoir cette nuit alors jacques
pendant que nous on lisait on est un
petit peu englué n'y a pas d'autre mot
dans leur confinement la chine elle
evans a déjà tourné la page de
l'épidémie et oui c'est fini
la crise sanitaire la base c'est du
passé ou presque et dire c'est pas vrai
que pour la chine a c'est vrai aussi
pour des pays comme taiwan 2 vietnam ou
la corée alors il faut comprendre que
ces pays ils ont réagi de manière
indifférente à l'amiante en régie les
pays européens et ce qui fait qu'il
semble épargner en particulier par cette
fameuse deuxième vague que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
le résultat c'est évidemment que leur
économie ont beaucoup moins souffert de
l'épidémie et surtout qu'elles
reprennent leurs activités beaucoup plus
vite que nous rien le traité qui a été
signé le 15 novembre dernier vous savez
ce fameux air ce pays où ce partenariat
économique régionale globale et d'un
indicateur aussi de comment les choses
sont en train d'évoluer
alors la question évidemment qu'on se
pose tous est ce que ces pays on
appliquer des mesures plus ou moins
sévères que nous face à la pandémie
alors une question intéressante c'est
fini cela dépend en fait on voit quand
on compare à un petit peu les mesures
qui ont été prises par ces pays que
certains ut ont pris des mesures qui
étaient très faibles d'autres ont pris
des mesures qui aidé par contre
extrêmement sévère on voit par exemple
que à taiwan les mesures ont été légères
mais que en corée au vietnam en cours
lit encore plus en chine évidemment il
ya on est en présence de mesures qui ont
été extrêmement sévère pourtant et là où
il faut regarder un petit peu sur l'axé
vertical du graphique
eh bien ces mesures ont beaucoup moins
détériorés l'activité économique
que les mesures qui ont été prises chez
nous en fait ce qui est en cause c'est
le fait que ces mesures ont souvent été
très différente incident les différents
pays asiatiques ont fermé leurs
frontières
ce que la france en particulier s'est
refusé à faire pour des raisons qui sont
essentiellement idéologique
le résultat c'est que nous avons connu
un recul de notre activité qui est
beaucoup plus important
alors jacques comment cela se traduit-il
sur l'activité précisément stéphanie
selon que l'activité est plutôt
industriels ou plutôt dans les services
évidemment il ya des différences on l'a
vu par exemple dans le graphique
précédent avec le cas de la russie dont
l'économie est essentiellement centré
sur l'industrie mais si on prend en
compte uniquement justement cette c'est
cette question de l'industrie eh bien on
voit que l'encore la chute de la
production en chine
elle a été plutôt plus faible que dans
les autres pays et que l la chine s'est
redressée beaucoup plus rapidement par
exemple quatre mois après le pic de la
crise la chine avait retrouvé son niveau
de décembre 2019 alors que en août c'est
à dire quatre mois après le pic d'avril
aucun des pays que ce soit les
etats-unis la russie ou la france man
n'avait retrouvé plus de 95% de ce
fameux niveau
ainsi la france a été le pays le plus
affecté et la russie est le pays qui a
le moins souffert d'une certaine manière
mais on voit très bien que quatre mois
après la crise ils sont
approximativement au même niveau mais
pourquoi c'est forcément la question
qu'on a envie de vous poser jacques
alors il ya plusieurs raisons d'abord il
faut dire que en chine d'amy a surtout
été concentrées dans la province du
hubei
là où se trouve la ville de one les
mesures de confinement qui ont été
prises localement on était très très
sévères elles l'ont été moins dans le
reste du pays et donc l'activité
économique a un petit peu moins souffert
après ce qui est frappant c'est que la
chine a quasiment interrompu ses
communications avec le reste du monde
le transport aérien encore aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il faut le souligner n'est
qu'à 5 ou 6 % de ce qu'il était avant
l'épidémie et on observe
la même chose avec le taiwan avec taiwan
la corée ou avec le vietnam tous ces
pays ont fermé leurs frontières ont mis
en place des règles de 14 n extrêmement
stricte sur les personnes qui souhaitait
y entrer et d'ailleurs il en va de même
pour la russie alors quelles seront les
conséquences de cette situation
alors il est absolument évident c'est
fanny que non seulement les pays qui
sont autour de la chine a été moins
affectée mais surtout qu'il semble se
relever et bien plus
et on va le voir d'ailleurs sur un
graphique on voit là que si on regarde
les taux de croissance tels qu'ils
étaient estimés avant la deuxième vague
parce que ce sont des calculs qui ont
été faits mais qui ont été faits au mois
de septembre
eh bien on voit que l'écart se creuse de
manière tout à fait spectaculaire entre
les pays développés comme la france
l'allemagne le japon et des etats-unis
d'un côté et la chine de l'aude
alors bien évidemment avec les
conséquences économiques du continent
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
eh bien on va avoir cet écart se creuse
et encore plus les pays qui ont su
préserver en partie leurs économies
comme l'allemagne ou les états unis
seront peut-être un petit peu moins
affecté que ceux qui ont plus ou moins
arrêter leurs activités mais ils
prendront un aussi un retard important
sur la chine est globalement sur toutes
les aiguilles du sud est enfin la cause
de 19 et bien elle a été révélatrice de
tendances moore qui sont présentes en
réalité depuis dix à vingt ans alors
concrètement cette année bien c'est à
dire que ça fait des années
en réalité que les pays européens que la
zone euro accumulent du retard dans son
développement
la croissance moyenne de la zone euro a
été l'une des plus faibles du monde
depuis l'institution de l'euro et là on
le voit sur ce graphique aussi on voit
que nous allons être pour les prochaines
années en récession
plusieurs années alors que les pays
émergents dont les pays d'asie
évidemment il est en particulier eux
et bien ils vont continuer à se
développer extrêmement rapidement même
la russie va faire mieux que la zone
euro dans ces prochaines années
alors il ya essentiellement deux raisons
à cela
il y a le fait que l'euro joue le rôle
d'un espèce dès qu'une fois à la
croissance mais il ya aussi le fait que
nous sommes en fait spectateurs autour
de lui d'une croissance qui tend à se
développer essentiellement dans la zone
asie-pacifique qui est en train de
devenir le pôle de croissance mondiale
seulement ce pôle va être sous contrôle
chinois
et c'est ici que prend tout son sens
l'accord de libre échange qui a été
signé à pékin le 15 novembre
le rcp et qui inclut et c'est na ble
points intéressants y compris des pays
qui ont des relations politiques plutôt
difficile avec la chine
donc en clair jacques ça veut dire que
le coleader 19 c'est un petit peu la fin
de l'europe telle que nous la
connaissons
mais oui c'est un risque si on n'y fait
rien si on ne prend pas des mesures le
retard que nous sommes en train de
prendre et qu'il sera cumulatif or ce
retard va nous mettre dans une situation
difficile
le jour où nous aurons à négocier avec
la chine l'exemple du ralliement de
l'australie ou de la nouvelle zélande à
l'accord chinois doit nous servir de
leçon
si nous continuons sur ce chemin ce sera
la sat idéalisation politique mais aussi
la satellisation économique
seulement la question qui se pose c'est
pour nous combler ce retard avec le
carcan de l'euro bien ça on peut
malheureusement au bout d'un merci
jacques peut-être que certains
entendront votre avertissement merci à
vous